we welcome you back to CBS mornings and
more coverage of the midterm elections
right now we're taking a close look at
the political power of women for decades
women have held a majority in the
electorate back in 2018 midterms they
made a 52 percent of the voters that's
compared to 48 for the men so we spoke
with four women of different backgrounds
from across the country about what's
driving them to the polls why are they
going we're going to start with Irene
codillo she is 57 years old she's a
Democrat from Kansas Bonnie Barton is 80
years old she's a republican from
Georgia Brianna day is 18. she is voting
for the first time from Texas she's a
registered independent she told us she's
nervous but very excited about this and
Imani Samuels is a Democrat from
Washington D.C here's what they told us
about issues that matter to them ahead
of tomorrow's elections
so everybody knows economy and inflation
are top issues for Women Voters you
would agree with that oh absolutely
even though I am retired uh and 80. uh I
still think about finding a job to
supplement you know I'm whatever I know
I can do something I've got a fairly
sharp mind you have a very sharp mind
but do you want to work do you want
um or you're doing it because you think
you have to I think I I want to uh
right now I'm taking care of my brother
who is slightly disabled and my husband
who may come home from a nursing home
what I want to do is take some of the
pressure off of my children who have
been helping me are you one of those
Women Voters where it is top of mind for
you and has your budget been affected
yes it is absolutely top of mind for me
and the CFO of our household my husband
the CFO of the household your husband
yes he was a CEO
but we have we have regular reviews of
our budget
um and gas definitely has gone up
um we are paying a lot in groceries uh
at one point in time
lunch at school for our kids was free
because of covid we are now back to
paying their lunch every day
which adds up let's talk about abortion
that also seems to be a hot button issue
where people seem to break among among
party lines it seems to be very top of
mind for Democratic women and not so
much for Republican women as we sit and
look at the numbers is that an issue
that will drive you to the polls one way
or the other yes it will drive me to the
polls with the political polarization
that we have in this country everyone's
on different sides and super extreme and
when it comes to an
abortion in the state sanctity of life I
think we need that's an issue where we
need to
maybe be in the gray area we can't be
black and white if that makes sense I
also think the overturning of Roe v Wade
is sending a lot of girls my age to the
polls and I see that amongst my friends
we all feel very passionately in our own
ways I also can't see no abortion at all
without respect of rape incest or the
mother's life did the Supreme Court do
the right thing in overturning Roe v
Wade Imani you go first on that I mean
absolutely not I think that
to be in a woman's body is a very
special thing and to have had two of my
own if I didn't feel confident in
raising them and and nourishing them in
such a prosperous way I want a choice
Bonnie did the Supreme Court do the
right thing in overturning Rogue white
what they did was they sent it back to
the States didn't they
so it's a state situ now
and it did overturn it I believe it yeah
I believe that every state needs to make
that decision every voter in each state
need to make that decision
that's being an individual
so that was they did the right decision
yeah I believe so Brianna
um I agree with Bonnie I also think they
made the right decision
it's up to
the state governments up to their
Congress to make that decision so it's
not completely gone away right per se
Irene
hi metal I'm shocked that the decision
was made I think about my daughters they
I do not think they made the right
decision I think what about the point
it's not going away it's not going to be
up to the state all right so now now
every state has to battle so Kansas just
have battled an issue on their ballot in
the primaries and it was not just
Democrat women that came out I'm
thankful for the Republican
white women diverse women who made a
decision
that felt that this is truly a woman's
health issue should be discussed with a
professional doctor that determines what
is right for the individual and what's
right for their situation so I think
we're making it difficult by passing it
to the state yeah many people would
agree with you and say it now makes
things much more complicated it is more
complicated
it's a complicated issue and I also
think just because
we do agree or me and Bonnie agree that
it was the right decision doesn't mean
we don't care about women's health
because I didn't say that or I didn't
say you didn't care it's about like
life you know right and
we have different perspectives and you
do and and I'm not saying you don't care
about the baby or you don't care about
the woman I'm just saying to me that is
such a personal decision the last
presidential election was top of mind
too I guess one of the reasons I like
President Trump was he says we're going
to build a wall and he did it well
almost president Trump also says that
the election was stolen do you believe
the election was stolen no you don't I
honestly don't no really I really don't
know
it's true it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter at this point
we are where we are
we need to figure out how we're going to
get
to a better place is anybody at the
table concerned about voter fraud for
this election I think I'm more worried
about
um
what constraints and and what we've done
to make it harder to vote because
there's so much discussion about fraud
that has not been introduced do you
believe the last election was stolen
think so
um I think it would be very hard to
steal an entire election but also at the
same time also at the same time there
were investigations into it multiple
investigations which had no nothing what
do you all think is at stake this
election
I think
um
personal freedom is at stake
humanity is at stake
um
I think about all of these things
they're all levers being able to feel
confident in your livelihood
that that's something we need oh my
goodness what's at stake is moving
movement forward
opportunity to rebuild after the
pandemic in a way that values people
over politics
hmm I think they all agree with that
people over politics it's interesting
when you get people together to have a
coherent conversation it really can be
done because clearly as you see they
didn't all agree on it on everything but
I think at the bottom line everybody is
just exhausted by all of this I don't
care who you who you believe what party
you are everybody's just exhausted they
want this day to be over so we can move
forward in whatever whatever that is
going to mean yeah that's well that's
the big question is if if we move
forward or whether the disappointment
from one election lingers and creates
this sense of ongoing exhaustion you can
argue we've been exhausted by elections
for many different Cycles now for sure
at the very base of it you feel that
people just want their future to be
tailor-made for their needs yes there
has to be some compromise if we're going
to get along collectively as a country
yeah and you know another thing is also
maybe politics doesn't have to keep
being at the center of your life all the
time you can have a chance to think
about something else but right people
don't feel like they have the luxury to
do especially this time of year